in our global outlook we're staying on
the markets and some might say this
current market route that you're seeing
in the u.s uh caused and tipped off by
what's going on in europe olivia stearns
you've been watching the european
markets and they are deep in the red
they are deep in the red we have seen a
little bit of a recovery in u.s stocks
so the dow off only by about 1.25
percent in europe the euro stocks 50
down 3 percent right now that means it
is down more than 12 percent since its
peak back in june the cacharanta the
burst in paris that is down about 2.8
percent right now the ftse milan is
trading down
3.62 percent right now a lot of the same
catalysts a lot of the same fear factors
of course the patient died of ebola in
germany yesterday that's joking concerns
you saw the sell-off uh pick up momentum
after those disappointing u.s retail
sales uh in athens the stock market
there down 10 percent today alone so a
lot of fear there uh perhaps some nerves
that we could see another resurgence of
the euro zone crisis uh mike our
economics editor mike uh what's the fed
to do here the fed is just going to sit
and watch markets tend to have tantrums
and that doesn't affect the overall
economy if there is an impact at the
moment it might be good because oil
prices are lower that's good for
consumers bond prices are down that
should push mortgage rates lower so the
long-term impact may not be all that bad
the fed's just going to sit back and
wait and watch see what happens
okay they are certainly going to wait
and as you mentioned they can't respond
to every single
tantrum that is happening in the markets
and we are a scarlet recovering at least
as olivia said from our lows of the
session so far from our early caution
but this is uh there's only been one day
in the past seven in which the
industrials has not moved at least 100
points and that was yesterday so we're
back in the volatile swing of things a
lot of people are saying over the summer
it's too quiet it's too quiet well we've
come back in a big way